so in the last video we talked about
tf-idf which is a core concept of how
information retrieval algorithms work
and we looked at essentially how many
times each word is in each document and
with that words important in that
document or not in this video we're
going to look at how web search engines
use that and what else they use to help
you find websites when you search online
when Sir Tim berners-lee first created
the web he used to keep a list in the
back of his book as to which were the
new websites of online so we had the
first hundred websites in his book on
the back page so he could tell people
what they were and so of course it
wasn't long then for someone created a
website which was these are the current
new websites that exist on the web and
then that this got obviously too big and
so then someone said well we should
build and to search through that list of
websites to try and find what we want to
find and so boom now we have search
engines but for all the websites that
exists so there's several things about
the web and searching online which are
different to when we've been searching
to a computer or when we search through
a collection of files and an online
library and the reason it's different is
because first of all there's millions
and millions of websites now and they're
never-ending and we still don't have an
idea of all of them there's still some
more search engines haven't found and so
it's this set that we don't know how big
it is and so we immediately can't really
say is this document important in the
whole set because we're struggling to
find out or the whole set is the first
thing we need to do is improve an
algorithm in the backend which finds all
of those documents and this is called a
spider or something that will crawl the
web and basically all it does is it say
oh it's been a while since we've checked
that web site a wonderful change since
we last went there maybe it has
different words in it now we'll go and
check it and then when it gets there it
says oh there's a new link here let's go
see if it's a website that's new that we
haven't seen before so for us that link
analyzer that page and it just
continually crawls the web finding more
and more pages what's actually happening
when a spider crawls aside is it
actually the equivalent the browser's
are looking at a site looking through
the text or what's actually going on
there and so when a spider hits a web
site it tends to be looking more at the
code so it can see lots of things in
there like which words in the web page
of titles and you can see that from the
code which words are about pictures and
so on and so it's analyzing all sorts of
things but essentially looking at all
the code in the web site and all the
words in the web site and then it's
creating more information in the index
so that the index is bigger and those
more documents but this job is mainly
just to read all the words not really
look at how pretty there's necessarily
and then put that information in so the
second thing that is interesting about
the web is that all web sites have a
kind of structure to them in the code
which you don't necessarily have from
documents in libraries and things or not
as easily to get so a website might have
words which are in brackets which
indicate that isn't a title so we can
say this has got the word horse in it
but it also has the word horse in the
title so let's give it double points for
being an important word it can look at
metadata in the website so there's some
times it says the metadata for this is
that it's about horses which is a good
clue thank you for telling us it's about
horses that kind of helps and also might
be that you search for my lovely horse
comm and that comes up quickly because
horses in the address not just in the
document itself so we're finding all
sorts of ways that we can say we can
give bonus points of things because they
are in special places in the website so
another thing exciting about websites
which is necessarily about documenting
libraries or documents and computers is
that they're linked to each other we
have links and so one page has a link
partway down which says you should look
at that page because it's interesting
and so the major thing that Google did
which is what they published in the 90s
which is what set up the whole Google
company was they said well let's take
advantage of that for every website
which sends a link let's say that is
that website saying that website is
pretty interesting and worth reading and
so they create something called page
rank which is essentially how many
people think a website is important
because of how many times they link to
it and so page rank works by saying well
let's give every website a bunch of
points let's say 100 points and every
time it links to a website it gives off
a portion of those points to the other
website so I mean a website with lots of
links in it is giving away a very small
amount of points to lots of other
websites but then if a website has got
thousands websites linking to it its
receiving loads and loads of points and
so it builds up a score of being an
important website so that means the
websites which is linked to most have
the biggest score and they're the
biggest websites and the most important
ones on the web any website that links
to is probably getting a nice sizable
number of points and so it's maybe a
medium-size website because an important
website links to it and then all the
websites which aren't really receiving
many links but linking outwards they're
kind of probably less important websites
and so less important to return on the
search engine and so this is the basic
principles of how PageRank works and so
then Google and say well we know this
course
using something like tf-idf as to how
many times the words are in those is
probably these thousand they're kind of
related to what they want and then we
say well let's put the ones which had
the biggest page rank at the top because
they're the most important ones and so
we'll prioritize the ones have the words
and you want most and the ones which
people think are most important we have
a combined score which is how important
that website is and whether it should be
at the top of the results can now age
right sometimes be more important than
the words it can be so the words so this
is part of us not knowing exactly how
Google works and exactly how much weight
they put on each of these measures is
they might say that the page rank is a
bit more important than number of words
it has in it but you still want it to
have those words in it to be considered
for page rank in the first place or
considered for combining with page rank
in this occasion so there you can
imagine there's one large index which is
how important are all the websites on
the Internet another one which is how
many times each word is in the internet
and all over the websites on the
internet and then they combine the score
rather than add them together so they
somehow mix them together with a weight
to say a bit more of that and a bit of
that and then we know that they then
have these two hundred features which
they're calling Google Panda this is
their name for their set of features
which they don't really reveal which is
about 200 different features along the
lines of how important is it when people
make the search is it the thing they
click on most is it very new is out of
date is it well designed in the sense
that it works for mobile phone for
searching on a mobile phone does it
conform to standards is it accessible to
people with disabilities is it relevant
because it's in the same location the
user am I looking for a horse and pony
show because it's in Nottingham it might
ask what does max usually search about
does he usually search about horses
why is he in fact weighted with horses
maybe he's just currently looking for a
present for someone who likes horses
maybe max is a computer scientist so he
likes Trojan horses viruses is asking
all those types of questions to say
maybe we can boost those topics because
they're Max's profile or we can build
that we can boost that topic because
it's in Max's location and we can boost
it because it's a good quality website
and boosting is a popular website amber
has got the right words in it
there's hundreds of functions and they
don't really tell us what they're doing
necessarily severe like the KFC special
yeah we're a little bit mix of
everything we maybe know what
ingredients in there but not how much I
mean one thing I'm thinking don't take
this a criticism but we're using Google
as a huge example of this I mean all the
really the websites really out there
we're thinking about or so this yeah
there's a lot of search engines and
they're all doing this type of thing and
the thing that makes them different is
maybe how they use these measures so
there's Bing of course which is
Microsoft's one yahoo has done a lot of
web search over time
Yandex is Russia's most popular one and
so these are all using these same kind
of algorithms but they're competing for
which combination is giving the best
type of results in another video we can
go through kind of exactly how they
determine what counts the best results
because there's all sorts of ways of
deciding that but they're essentially
kind of competing in with secret sauce
for how much they can get the right the
right results to the top and then people
vote in numbers based on which ones seem
to be coming out right and seem to make
sense to them forgive the food knowledge
ease it's coke versus Pepsi though yeah
I guess so they're both probably using a
ton of ingredients all of which are
giving them scores and they're just
trying to decide which of those scores
are best and they're also competing for
who can produce that score better so if
they improve the tf-idf type algorithm
slightly and don't tell anybody else
about it then not only are they waiting
that slightly differently but they're
also improving the score that weighting
is based on so they can tweak all of
these different algorithms all these
different points of measures and then
tweak how they combine them all together
to get the best results and presumably
the only way to test that is by putting
it by is that so there's lots of
different ways that you could test
whether an algorithm has got better the
people with luxury of having millions of
users hitting the servers all the time
they will do some different tests on
different servers to say on this
algorithm we we boosted PageRank
slightly and everyone who went to that
server clicked on the top result more
often so maybe we've got a better result
and so then they make all of the servers
like the one that did best and then I
say right well let's take that server
and will increase the weighting of how
important words and titles are and then
if that doesn't have any significant
impact then they don't bother deploying
that across all services so this is a
type of test with 1% of your population
and then spread it across everywhere
else in these videos there's a lot of
things which I've told you in a lot of
things which I haven't had time
because there's so many different things
that people have done as I said 60 years
of research where people have come up
with new ways of improving the way that
we decide whether a document is relevant
or not relevant I haven't even talked
about how you measure relevance and not
relevant and so there's many many things
which have been done over 60 years which
are been significant improvements so if
you want to learn more than leave a
comment about the types of things you
want to understand and we'll see if we
can find you more deep details about it
and these five documents have those
words in different mass times so
document one has got the word mine at 25
times unsurprisingly how big the target
is exactly it's having a landing pad
you've got exactly so the width gives
you an idea about exactly how accurate
you need to be